IC POLICY WENT WITH DOCTOR
EVIL OUTFIT.
WHO WORE IT BETTER?
THEN NANCY AND CHUCK AS
PARENTS.
WE ARE NOT MAD WE ARE JUST
DISAPPOINTED.
MY FAVORITE FACE SWAP.
AS GREG SAYS THE OTHER DAY THE
RESPONSE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWED BY PAID FOR BY DONALD
TRUMP FOR PRESIDENT EXHIBIT
NUMBER TWO ANOTHER POLITICAL
OPPONENT CN AND WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT WENT DOWN TO
TEXAS ON THE BORDER HE DOESN'T
WANT A WALLET DOESN'T BELIEVE
THERE IS ANY CRISIS AT THE
BORDER BUT HE POSTED A VIDEO
THAT DESTROYED HIS OWN
ARGUMENT.
>> HERE ARE THE STEEL SLATS
THE PRESIDENT TALKS ABOUT
RIGHT HERE.
YES YOU CAN SEE THROUGH TO THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE US-MEXICO
BORDER BUT WE ARE NOT SEEING
ANY KIND OF IMMINENT DANGER
ARE NO IMMIGRANTS TO RUSH TO
THE FENCE HERE IN THIS AREA AS
MATTER OF FACT THERE ARE
BUSINESSES THERE IS A GAS
STATION OR BURGER KING BUT NO
SIGN OF THE NATIONAL EMERGENCY
AS A MATTER OF FACT IT'S
PRETTY TRANQUIL.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSE: PERHAPS BECAUSE THERE
IS A BORDER FENCE THEY ARE NOT
RUSHING TO THE FENCE BECAUSE
THERE IS A FENCE ILLEGALS
CROSS WHERE THERE IS NO FENCE.
IS HE WORKING FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP OR CNN CRACK SOMETIMES
IT'S HARD TO TELL.
WHAT AN EMBARRASSMENT.
EXHIBIT NUMBER THREE BETO
O'ROURKE A SENSATION ON SOCIAL
MEDIA LIKES TO BRING VOTERS
INTO HIS WORLD SOMETIMES
COOKING STEAK IN THE KITCHEN
BUT HE TOOK IT A STEP TOO FAR
THIS WEEK.
>> I AM HERE AT THE DENTIST WE
WILL CONTINUE OUR SERIES WITH
PEOPLE ON THE BORDER.
SHE WILL TELL US ABOUT GROWING
UP.
JESSE: HOPING THAT YOU DO NOT
HAVE A COLONOSCOPY ANYTIME
SOON.